to me a lot of Italian people say I'm  passionate when they do yeah yeah and  people would take that the wrong way as  arrogant ignorant loud but I just think  they're passionate yeah exactly that's  exactly that's exactly but I think I  think that's like a lack of femininity  that's like I think like typically when  when I hear girls say this and some some  behavior that they do that's like a lack  of femininity to men and that's what's  putting them off well I've never heard  that before I'm absolutely  no no in a sense that um even what she  said like and this is someone like I can  be loud too I'm not I'm not above it but  I'm I'm just saying like when when she  said like loud like the traits that  Auntie just used that's not none of them  are feminine traits and so men don't  typically like loud girls you know I was  me I talk a lot okay